i think that that's very accurate um
and i mean i think that we're going to
look back on what 2020 was and obviously
we're not through this thing and we're
you know a quarter of the way through
2021 but um
this has been a huge shift
in terms of our consciousness as
humanity
in terms of everything that happened in
2021 the black lives matter movement the
political race the iv you know the
pandemic
everything was just kind of this melting
pot of
um of change and
it was uncomfortable and we continued to
feel that
um you know you brought up canceled
culture
and one thing that in relation to what
you were talking about earlier that i
think is so dangerous with cancer
culture is it doesn't allow people
to grow um we
are we become so afraid of making a
mistake that we don't say anything
and that's not where that's not where we
need to be right now you know
as all of us and i think that we need to
be having the uncomfortable
conversations about race we need to be
having the um you know those
conversations with our family members
with you know we need to use our
platforms we need to be
bringing issues to the forefront but if
we're so scared that we're going to get
cancelled that we're going to say the
wrong thing that
something's not going to be perfectly
worded or politically correct
we need to feel i think as people um
that we can make mistakes and
not be persecuted for them and you know
not that we shouldn't be held
accountable
but that these mistakes end up
in potentially getting cancelled that's
just dangerous
it's it's really dangerous and i think
that that whole kind of
movement around this person's done like
this like you know 23 year old said this
thing they're done forever
like that is so um
it's dangerous and i'm worried that
you know this next generation and all of
our generations that we're living
through right now
are are going to be so paralyzed that we
just don't say
anything because we don't want to be we
i want to be called out
and the fear of getting called out is
greater than the fear
that than the action of speaking truth
well said
people need to think about that you
think about why you do and don't say
something and what's in line with your
truth
and i feel like if there's one thing
that you have done
so well with your music
through your music with yourself but
through your music
is be honest and you talk about
things that are happening in culture
that people aren't talking about you
talk about things that are happening
with yourself that people aren't
talking about um with themselves
personally
and um so it makes me kind of
want to ask the question
what do you want to say how do you want
to
what do you want to tell people what do
you want to say to them what do you want
to wake them up to how do you want to
like how how can we elevate our
consciousness to the point where we can
all start to get along like look i have
friends who are
we don't all believe in the same thing
at all i have and and that's and that's
what i realized is that we all get along
great as people i'm like wow there's all
these like surface level beliefs that
are different
but we have an amazing time together and
have so much fun and we're so much more
alike than we are
different and so how how i don't know
what do you
how you you're a change maker through
your through your platform
what do you want to say oh adam that's a
huge
question i i do think that what you're
talking about is interesting in terms of
your friendship groups i think that with
you know the how intense it got with
trump it really
created a line in the sand in terms of
um yeah who you could even be friends
with like
the family members that you would talk
to or not talk to like it got
that divisive and um
that's also you know when it's just
black or white
when it's just you know you're on this
side or that side those are
really um that's a scary place for
for society to be in you know there's no
nuance and
it is something that makes our what what
makes our country
you know so interesting is that we have
people from all
different walks of life we are uh
extremely diverse country as a whole
and yet if we're either have to pick
right or left
then we're not getting into the core
belief system of what really makes this
integral experience of humanity like
like
even the ability to connect her to see
differences like i
can i completely have the same
experience and i think that
with with friendship groups of not
feeling the same not being aligned i
don't
grow if i'm just around like-minded
people i don't i don't
i don't actually um i'm not
i'm not pressed to actually think about
a different way of of
of life when i've opened up my circle
and you know honestly a big part of this
did come through recovery
um when i open up my circle and i'm like
damn i didn't think that i would have
anything in common with you i judge you
i looked the way that you were dressed
i looked at the car that you pulled up
and i looked at the accident that you
had
i looked at you know how you sat i
looked at the coffee
all these things that are subconsciously
happening that we are just
stacking up to judge somebody who they
are um
all of that math was completely wrong
it was completely wrong and actually who
you truly are at your core
i love i love and
looking for the similarities rather than
the differences
i think that it's so easy to look at to
look at the differences and be like no
we don't have to
that doesn't make sense that's not what
i believe in um
and it's more complex than that and the
other thing the internet makes
makes all of this worse right the
internet is
um a place where people you know
it's like when you have a conversation
with someone there's people that i
that i have great conversations with but
when they text me i'm like this is like
a completely different person
like this level of communication is is
is
horrible like you know and then i i'm
like damn like they really this is
this is so bizarre and then i talk to
them in person and i'm reminded
oh yeah when you type something out
and press upload or send or comment or
whatnot
there is no tone to that there is no
personality to that
and people speak in absolutes and they
and they have a next level of
bold expertise that might not exist in
real life when you're one on one
so i think that these are all more
reasons why community is important
having a different set of community
that's bigger than just an insular one
where we can actually learn from one
another